is the head coach of the new york jets
on the phone line
looks like you're rich long time
listener first time caller robert sala
rich eisen here how are you coach
how you guys doing well i'm better for
talking to you
how are you doing more importantly how
are you doing robert
blessed every day blessed every day
when did you first uh get a call from
the jets how quickly they call you up
robert salah how did that happen um i
believe the call came in that they
wanted to interview on wednesday after
the season somewhere around there
okay uh we had our zoom call on a friday
um i was in the building i believe
monday i mean
all the days are getting caught up in
sure right
but it went pretty quick it went pretty
quick so is it the first time you've
ever
communicated with joe douglas or or do
you have any history where you go back
or you've met or anything like that or
is this
completely fresh for you with the
johnson family and joe douglas
no it was the first time that i've ever
had any communication with joe and
as soon as people found out that i was
interviewing
and i'm talking about that zoom call the
amount of calls and texts
and uh excitement about
the about joe was it was effusive and so
it was going into it i was like man this
guy must be unbelievable
right so and he's lived up to the
building okay well i'll be honest with
you
uh coach you know um i'm from
full disclosure here um i'm born in
brooklyn raised in staten island new
york
you and i have never met i don't believe
right coach i don't think
i don't believe something i don't think
so we haven't even run into the combine
which is kind of crazy but anyway i
watch you a lot though
i appreciate that i watch you too i
watch you too coach
i see you all fired up and and um you
know uh i'm i'm just gonna unburden
myself here and this usually doesn't
happen in interviews and i hope it
doesn't get too
sideways but i'm born in brooklyn raised
in staten island if
we were here i would show you the um
figurative scars of being a lifelong jet
fan die hard
died in the wool okay i go way way back
and when i'm hearing how great everyone
loves joe douglas and everyone loves you
too
i've heard nothing but effusive praise
for you gets me nervous i'm not gonna
lie gets me a little nervous can you can
you help with that
coach can you help with that you know i
don't know it's um
i i guess it's one of those deals you
just have to just just observe and
and trust the process and see how this
thing goes okay so what is your process
lay it out for me what do you got for
you know it's uh obviously
i mean all the coach speak about um uh
uh evaluating the players and all that i
can bore you but the reality is
no matter what no matter what everything
we do from this day forward
uh is is designed with to win
championships
uh um and everything that we're going to
do is
is is going to be with the mind be
mindful of putting the players first
because they're the ones who strap
up and they're the ones who walk between
the white lines and they're the ones who
go to go to battle every day and so
um that's that's that's the intent and
we're gonna do it in a collaborative way
uh joe has been phenomenal through this
this whole
process so him and his staff uh working
with us in terms of finding
and putting our players in the best
positions possible be successful and uh
i just believe in my heart that when you
have people who collaborate and
communicate
to the level of uh what joe wants and
what what i would want uh it's hard to
fail
uh there's the old saying of where
there's a lack of communication
negativity
negativity fills the void and so you
can't
communicate enough to get what you need
to get done to make things work and so
uh i'm excited about it it's gonna be
it's gonna be a cool process so
are you a ceo head coach to use the
phrase are you you're
or you're you're delegating correct to
play callers is that what you're doing
yeah
i i i guess i mean however however
anybody wants to label it but uh
you know i've i've been very fortunate
um you know i've been blessed to be on
this
on with the kyle shanahan system if you
will for almost for about 10 years
of my coaching career and then obviously
we have the system that we were able to
evolve to when we're at san francisco
and so
um you know there's a there's a visual
uh that from a vision standpoint we know
what both sides of the ball including
special teams are supposed to look like
we know what the techniques are we know
what the players look like we know how
they operate within the scheme we know
the process at which they install
systems and the way they teach the drill
work we know all of it on both
in all three phases and so um
uh if you want to call a ceo type that's
that's for
other people it's just it's a matter of
coaching it's a matter of just making
sure that the vision of the organization
is being moved in the direction that we
want
in collaboration with joe and his staff
and then obviously offensive coordinator
defensive coordinator and special teams
and so
um it's uh it's going to be a cool
process
and and one that i just i feel like
everyone's on the same page with
robert salah here on the rich eisen show
the new head coach of the new york jets
here on this busy friday before
championship sunday which
uh coach sala coached on last year for
the san francisco 49ers and you
mentioned that you've been in the
shanahan system
does that mean the offense with mike
lafleur that the offense that we saw
with shanahan running it in san
francisco and wherever he's run it
that this is the type of offense that
you are in fact bringing to new york
city
and new jersey that is it for sure yeah
no no question
it's uh just from just speaking from a
defensive standpoint it's
it's a uh son on the go against on a
day-to-day basis
uh all the movement the personnel
groupings the
the formations it's they make it very
difficult from a communication
standpoint and then on top of it they
strain you both schematically
and they attack you from a player's
standpoint so there's just so many
different things that they do with
regards to marrying run and pass
creating big pockets for the quarterback
and wide open receivers
and they just at the and at the end of
the day they make it
while i'm straining you so much on
defense they make the game so simple for
the quarterback
and uh to be able to to get mikey uh
leflore
forgive me i call him mikey he wants
something called mike okay no problem
but to get mikey he's um uh he's
he's been with kyle since he got in the
league so he was there with him in
cleveland when they built that one up uh
i know it only lasted a year or so but
he was there he
went to atlanta they rebuilt that one
had matt ryan as a league mvp go to san
francisco rebuild that one
and so now he's ready to to do it
himself and so
there's no doubt in my mind that he'll
uh he'll be able to do the same things
that his brother has done over at uh
green bay with with regards to getting
that offense back up and running and
and and the people who have been uh
attached to kyle and and branched off
away from him
so part of your conversations with joe
douglas
and uh christopher johnson um and you
have still yet to
chat with woody right the the returning
owner of the jets is that correct
correct
okay are you on do we do we have an
appointment or
are we where are you on that process i'm
supposed to meet with him soon
obviously he's been traveling yeah
really excited for that opportunity to
sit down and talk with them and
uh uh build a relationship with them
okay and then
um the quarterback um and sam darnold
was that part of your process talking to
joe douglas
and christopher johnson did they ask you
your opinion of him
how how much of sam darnold was
discussed in your
interview process that led to your
hiring yeah
of course there was a discussion the
quarterback is the most important
position
on the football team by far he's uh most
important player uh
in every organization and so he was he
was discussed and
and uh and i think we have equal belief
in sam in terms of uh his arm talent his
mobility his fearlessness in the pocket
his ability to process information and
make great decisions
uh he is a there's a reason why he was
the number three pick
uh and he's only 23 years old so he's
there's no question that
sam is capable of being a starter in
this league and uh has the ability to
play at a very high level so
um you know we're excited to get with
sam and talk with him more and continue
to
uh uh develop our relationship with him
have you connected with him yourself
so far yeah i've had a chance to reach
out to um
everybody via text and then a couple of
guys i've been able to get a hold of on
the phone i'm still trying to catch up
and uh and then a couple of guys have
been able to walk into the office so
i would love to to have face time with
every single
uh uh man that's on this roster uh
before
we see him for ota but you have had a
conversation
with sam or is he just one of the text
guys that you no
uh we've been able to speak and have
conversations okay look i i
cause i understand that you know look he
is just an aces person i don't know if
you're aware but when he when he signed
with the jets the first thing he did
before his press conference
was to visit a children's hospital i
mean he he could not be more
of a stand-up wonderful human uh
but there's so many questions about his
his um
future and so currently right now
uh is he the quarterback of of the new
york jets starting
2021 robert solomon you know i've i've
got this belief that um
you know while when you're here you're
going to get all of us and so we're
going to approach sam that way and
and he's like i said he's got an
unbelievable amount of arm talent and
all the different things i just talked
about but
in fairness to the process it's the same
thing that and it's every position
on this roster we're just starting to
dive in the tape the coaches are still
showing up we're still trying to figure
out where
people fit within the scheme that we
have and what um
whether there needs to be some position
changes or modifications or whatever
we're looking for there's
so there's an entire process that we
have to go through um
so we don't make just rash emotional
decisions but
uh i will go on record tell everyone
that sam is capable of being a starter
in this league and he is capable of
playing at a high level and
and his his talent shows it on tape when
you watch it
okay so before i let you go all gas no
breaks right is that what i need to
figure out myself that what it is no gas
no braking
oh no break no break no singular break
okay
no singular okay so all gas no break um
and that is in regards to just uh
the general sense of everything it's
life it's how you wake up in the morning
to prepare for your day it's how you
approach work it's how you approach your
meetings it's how you approach uh
practice it's how you approach people
it's how you approach being a
husband wife father
uh daughter son it's just it's just life
and uh
waking up in the morning stepping on the
gas and and pursuing
every which way you can to be better
when you go to sleep than when you woke
up
okay and um and that's the mindset how
many hands on the wheel
coach i want to get let's how many hands
do we have in the wheel both two hands
on the wheel cause that's none of the
gun better be going fast
okay okay that's a good one i like that
and then your hands free if you have to
call somebody obviously
keep your eyes on the road how excited
should i be you tell me come on now
what's the uh uh on behalf of every jet
fan
my god do we hope that this works out
for you and everybody
mooch tells me you're you know you're
you're from the northern michigan you're
gonna love them i mean i hear all that
stuff
so um how excited should i be robert you
know what
um i believe everybody everybody and i
really believe this with every fiber in
my body and includes fans
has a part of uh the success and failure
of an organization and so i encourage
everyone to dive in head first
and and come on for the ride and uh be
supportive
um and and enjoy this ride because there
is no doubt in my mind that one day we
will win championships i'm not gonna put
a time on it
but this organization will win
championships especially when you talk
to the people
uh uh with regards to christopher
johnson
joe douglas and jaime um
this organization is gonna win and uh
it's going to be a great ride
that was very nameth like coach i got to
be honest with you have you chatted with
joe has joe reached out have you chatted
with joey
i haven't i can't wait i can't wait to
meet him in person i can't wait
do you have a well do you have a do you
have do you have a fur coat uh
i you know i don't even have a coat i
gotta go buy one
you're not in california anymore man you
know i've i've been to jacksonville
houston california i haven't
oh my gosh uh but one last thing because
i know
uh our time is almost up here do you
have a system in place of somebody who's
gonna let you know when a challenge or
not
i'm an expert at this sort of thing this
is my area of expertise do you have
somebody set up
that is looking down at the field that
has the actual
dvr in front of that person to know when
to challenge and when to not that is
truly one of the most challenging things
you're going to have to deal with now
as the hc of the nyj do you have a
system like that set up
we will we're we are uh in the process
of looking for a game manager in terms
of someone in the box to handle that
stuff to keep us on top of analytics and
giving us all the information we need to
make the best decisions possible
okay well you know if you need any audio
visual help that you know
you said that everybody's chipping in um
you know just you you have my number now
it's basically what i'm saying if you
want to take a pay cut i'll take you
[Laughter]
i don't know i see mr johnson's bottom
line sir we might be able to shake a few
couch cushions free that's all i'm
saying but you know
that's for a different day i guess
thanks for the call coach congrats on no
thank you guys thank you so much can't
wait to meet you all in person right
back at you that is robert sala
everybody the new head coach the new
york jets
you're on the rich eisen show hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that
watch more right here